चलिए तो हम लाइव आ चुके हैं एंड आई थिंक र
लाइव नाउ
या
यप ओके सो वी आर लाइव नाउ या हम आ चुके
लाइव
[संगीत]
एंड चलिए तो हम लाइव आ चुके हैं एंड गुड
इवनिंग एवरी बडी सबको गुड इवनिंग मैं यहां
पर एक बार दूसरे अपने डिवाइस पर भी लाइव
को ऑन कर लेता
हूं ठीक
है जस्ट
वेट
ओके थोड़ा सा वेट
कीजिए चलिए सो गुड इवनिंग सबको सबको वेरी
वेरी गुड इवनिंग सभी को वेलकम टू दिस लाइव
सेशन एंड वेलकम टू द डे फ वेलकम टू द
क्लास फाइव ऑफ बग बाउंस राइट चलिए सबको
वेलकम
वेलकम हां ट चैनल पर नहीं डाला दिमाग से
मेरे गया था मैं ब बब शूट वाली एक्टिवेशन
वीडियो आज डाल दूंगा आपकी ठीक है
ी के बारे में रेकन कैसे करते हैं कैसे
प्रॉपर किसी टारगेट के बारे में
इंफॉर्मेशन कलेक्ट करते हैं जितनी
इंफॉर्मेशन कलेक्ट करनी चाहिए उतनी कैसे
करेंगे किस तरीके से आप वह सारी स्टेप्स
को करेंगे सब चीज जानने वाले हैं तो जल्दी
से फटाफट कर दीजिए गुड इवनिंग
सबको कॉपी पेन लेकर बैठ जाइए लैपटॉप को
ओपन कर लीजिए लैपटॉप पर अगर साथ में हो
सके मेरे साथ परफॉर्म कीजिए काली लिनिक्स
को ओपन करके रखिए अगर पॉसिबल है तो नहीं
तो कोई बात नहीं नहीं तो
चलेगा नोट्स तो बनाओ भाई नोट्स बनाना है
यस अगर आप लोग अगला आप लोग नोट्स बना सकते
हो तो प्लीज मेक श्यर
टू मेक योर ओन नोट
प्लीज ठीक
है
चलिए ओके आज 31 मना रहे हैं क्या सब आज
थोड़े कम लोग आए हैं मेरे ख्याल से 31 मना
रहे हो क्या
भाई सभी लोग चलिए हैंडसम लग रहे हो सर
धन्यवाद
नचिकेत यहां हमारे पास एक मैसेज आ रहे हैं
क्या मैसेज आ रहे हैं भैया के सर
यट में फुल क्लास मिलेगा क्या बग बाउंट का
पूरा क्लास मिलेगा भैया टेंशन नहीं लेने
का पूरी क्लास आपको मिलेगी उसकी टेंशन
आपको नहीं लेनी है आप यह मत सोचो कि आपको
आधी अधूरी क्लास मिलेगा य पर ठीक है
अा मैंने नीचे मोबाइल भी रख रखा है आपके
चैट को देखने के लिए तो मैं वहां से भी
आपके चैट देख
लूंगा तो आपको पूरा मिलेगा टेंशन नहीं
लेनी है चलिए लव फ्रॉम पाकिस्तान लव फ्रॉम
इंडिया
ब्रदर यहां पर फाइनल ईयर में तो फाइनल ईयर
में नो पार्टी ऑन तैयारी अच्छा कोई पार्टी
नहीं है तैयारी प है फाइनल ईयर में हो यह
भी बहुत बड़ी एक मुश्किल है यार कि फाइनल
ईयर में है चलो एम एग्जाम्स की प्रिपरेशन
कर रहे हैं है ना चलिए तो स्टार्ट करते
हैं गाज आज का सेशन वेलकम टू द डे फाइव ऑफ
फ्री बग बाउंट कोर्स एंड लाइव रिकॉन सेशन
आज से हम स्टार्ट कर रहे हैं रेकन की बहुत
बड़ी एक सीरीज चलने वाली है तो आपको रेकन
को रेकन को ही पढ़ना है रिकन को ही सोना
है रिकॉन को ही उठना है रिकॉन को ही खाना
है रिकॉन को ही पीना है हर चीज आपको रिकॉन
को ही करना है याद रखिएगा रिकन इज वेरी
वेरी वेरी मच इंपॉर्टेंट फॉर योर बग बाउंट
जर्नी बिना रिकन का भैया कुछ नहीं होगा
याद रखना तो एक बार अगर आपकी इजाजत हो तो
मैं पानी भी पी लेता हूं ठीक है लेट मी
हैव सम
वाटर
ओके
चलिए चलिए
तो 77 लोग हैं 50 लाइक हैं यह बहुत बड़ी
नाइंसाफी है यह तो नाइंसाफी करके ठाकुर यह
ठाकुर के साथ नाइंसाफी मत किया करो थोड़ा
सा इंसाफ दिया करो इंसाफ दिया करो यार मैं
तो इंसाफ दिया करता हूं आप भी तो इंसाफ दो
मुझे मतलब 77 लोग 50 लाइक कहां की इंसाफ
कहां की इंसाफ है भाई कौन से कोर्ट में
ऐसा इंसाफ होता है समझ नहीं आ रहा यार
मुझे तो
चलो जोग सपाट लेट्स स्टार्ट द क्लास आज के
क्लास में हम रेकन शुरू कर रहे हैं और
रेकन को स्टार्ट करने से पहले मैं आपको एक
बहुत इंपोर्टेंट चीज बता देता हूं कि रेकन
को हम एक अलग ही लेवल पर लेकर जाने वाले
हैं इस बग बाउंटीज जर्नी में एक नेक्स्ट
लेवल प लेकर जाने वाले हैं एंड यकीन करो
मैं आपको गारंटी के साथ कहता हूं कि इस
लेवल का रेकन अगर
आपको
youtube1 कुछ कुछ कंटेंट क्रिएटर्स हैं
फॉरेन के जिन्होंने काफी अच्छे रिकॉन के
सेशंस डाल रखे हैं आई एग्रीड बट स्टिल
उससे भी कई गुना ज्यादा और डिटेल आपको इस
रेकन वाली पूरी सीरीज में यानी बग बाउटी
की इस रेकन फेज में मिलने वाली है तो जस्ट
इमेजिन द डेप्थ ऑफ द क्वालिटी फॉर दिस बग
बांटी कोर्स फ्री कोर्स और हां एक चीज और
बताना चाहूंगा कि कोई भी चीज इंटरनेट पर
अगर आपको बिल्कुल फ्री मिल रही है तो वह
बिल्कुल फ्री नहीं होती है फैक्ट है यह
मैं आपको एकदम फ्री सेशन दे रहा हूं
बिल्कुल फ्री नहीं है क्यों क्यों फ्री
नहीं है क्योंकि मुझे उसके बदले में आप
लोग मिल रहे हो आप लोगों का सपोर्ट मिल
रहा है इतना बड़ा ऑडियंस हमारा बन रहा है
एक पूरी ऑडियंस बन रही है हमारी राइट तो
कोई भी अगर आपको बोल रहा है ना कि मैं
फ्री में ही बिल्कुल दे रहा हूं कुछ नहीं
ले रहा आपसे गलत बोल रहा है झूठ बोल रहा
है उसके बदले में आपको मेरे को मिल रही है
ऑडियंस ऑडियंस मिल रही है मेरा एक ऑडियंस
पूरा एक अच्छा खासा ऑडियंस मिल रहा है
मुझे आप लोगों का प्यार सपोर्ट मिल रहा है
सो नॉट इट्स नॉट फ्री उसके बदले में ग भी
मुझे पे करेगी आप लोग जो ऐड्स देखते हो आप
लोग जो चीजें देखते हो यहां पे
आप इस पूरे बक बाउंट कोर्स को कंप्लीट
कीजिए ठीक
है या बिल्कुल
इतना भी सच नहीं बोला अरे मतलब सच नहीं
मतलब मैं तो जेनरिक बात बता रहा हूं ना
यार मैं जेनरिक बात बता रहा हूं इतना भी
सच नहीं मैं जेनरिक बात बता रहा हूं एक यह
जेनरिक बात सब पे लागू होती है मुझ पर भी
लागू होती है ठीक है तो उतनी टेंशन नहीं
लेनी है मैं कुछ ऐसे हाइड करके ना पीच
पीछे वाली चीजें नहीं करता कभी भी मैं
बिल्कुल बिल्कुल फ्लांट एकदम बिना किसी
उसके फल कर सकता हूं किसी भी बात को जो
मैं बोलता हूं ठीक है तो आई जस्ट फ्लोट
चलिए ओके तो स्टार्ट करते हैं लाइव
रिकॉर्न सबसे पहले लाइव रिकन को स्टार्ट
करने से पहले हमें समझना है कि डोमेन
जिसके बारे में हम सारी जानकारी लेंगे वह
किस तरीके से काम करती है एक छोटा सा बस
आपको ओवरव्यू देना चाहता हूं हाउ डोमेन
वर्क्स ठीक है हाउ डोमेन वर्क्स यहां पर
आपको सामने कुछ दिख रहा है व्हाट यू आर
सेइंग पड एडमिन ब्लॉगड ex.com यह एक पूरा
आपको दिख रहा है इसमें एग्जांपल क्या है
रूट डोमेन है कॉ को हम टॉप लेवल डोमेन
बोलते हैं बॉ example.com ब्लॉग क्या हो
गया फर्स्ट सब डोमेन हो गई फर्स्ट लेवल का
सब डोमेन एडमिन blog.com हो गया क्या
blog.com का सब डोमेन
एडमिन blog.com हो गया अब
admin.com का सब डोमेन क्या हो गया .
admin.com तो ब्लॉग फर्स्ट लेवल का सब
डोमेन है आपका सेकंड लेवल का सब डोमेन
आपका है एडमिन एंड थर्ड लेवल का सब डोमेन
है आपका ऐप तो यह इस तरीके से पूरी रर की
काम करती है आपके सब डोमेन की एंड जब हम
रेकन को स्टार्ट करते हैं तो सब डोमेन
न्यूमरेशन इज़ द मोस्ट इंपॉर्टेंट थिंग सब
डोमेन न्यूमरेशन के बिना आपका टारगेट आपका
जो स्कोप है वह बड़ा नहीं होगा आज हम क्या
कौन सा स्कोप लेने वाले हैं आज हम कौन से
ऐसे डोमेन को टारगेट में लेने वाले हैं
फॉर लाइव रिकॉर्न तो मुझे आप बता बताए कि
कौन से एक बड़े डोमेन का नाम बताइए मतलब
ऐसे नहीं छोटे मोटा कंपनी मत बताना
क्योंकि बहुत कुछ उसकी डिटेल हम नहीं
निकाल पाते हैं रेकन में तो कोई एक बड़ा
कंपनी बताओ जिसकी वेबसाइट हम ले आज के
सेशन के लिए आपसे ही पूछ के चल रहा हूं
मुझे बताइए चैट में उसमें से मैं पिक कर
लूंगा लेट मी नो कोई बड़ी कंपनी उसकी
वेबसाइट बताओ जिसका ह्यूज स्कोप होता हो
एंड वी विल पिक दैट चलिए
बताइए सभी लोग
बताइए ओके अ ला इज देयर एक ला हमारे पास आ
गई है हम मैं इसमें से कोई से भी एक पिक
करूंगा बताइए ला आ गई चलिए अच्छी बात है
माइक्रोसॉफ्ट मेटा
चीज बतानी है उसके पहले एक कांसेप्ट आपको
समझाना है वो कांसेप्ट अगर समझेंगे तो ही
आज का सेशन समझ में आएगा प्रैक्टिकल जब आप
करेंगे तो आपको समझ में आएगा कि ये
प्रैक्टिकल में एक्चुअली हो क्या रहा है
पहली चीज वह है
सीआईडीआर सीआईडीआर दूसरी चीज है ए एस एन
ठीक है दो चीजें हैं जो आपको समझनी है
सीआईडीआर क्या होता है क्लासले इंटर डोमेन
राउटिंग इसको बोलते हैं क्लासले इंटर
डोमेन राउटिंग ये एक आईपी एड्रेस का
एलोकेशन मेथड आप बोल सकते हैं ठीक है जो
कि बड़ी कंपनीज यूज़ करती हैं अपने आईपी
पूल के लिए अब जैसे कोई बड़ी कंपनी होती
है ना तो बड़ी कंपनी क्या करती है उनके
पास एक लार्ज आईपी पूल होता है सर्वर्स की
ठीक है उसी आईपी पूल में उनके सारे
सर्विसेस होते हैं जिस पे जिसको वह ऑपरेट
कर रहे होते हैं छोटी कंपनीज में आईपी पूल
नहीं होती है छोटी कंपनीज या तो बेसिकली
आईएसपी वगैरह पे ऑपरेट कर कर रही होती है
उनका खुद का एक सर्वर होता है छोटा सा
सर्वर हो गया एक उसपे काम कर रहे होते हैं
सिंपल बट बड़ी-बड़ी कंपनी जैसे
आईडी आर रेंज आप बोल सकते हैं यह कहा जाता
है ठीक है पहली चीज तो यह हो गई आईपी
एड्रेस को एफिशिएंटली एलोकेट करने के लिए
सीआईडी आर बस इतना ही समझना है ज्यादा
ज्यादा ना वो कंफ्यूज नहीं होना है दूसरा
होता है ऑटोनोमस सिस्टम नंबर या एएस नंबर
आप इसको बोल सकते ऑटोनोमस सिस्टम नंबर
यहां इसका मतलब क्या है एक वे है टू
रिप्रेजेंट अ कलेक्शन ऑफ आईपीस एंड हु ओनस
देम बस एक कलेक्शन ऑफ आईपी को रिप्रेजेंट
करने और कौन उसको ऑन करता है उसके लिए
एएसएन नंबर होता है ऑटोनोमस सिस्टम नंबर
होता है ठीक है अब यहां पे आपको दिख रहा
होगा पीपीटी पे द आईपी एड्रेस पुल इ
स्प्रेड अक्रॉस फाइव रीजनल इंटरनेट
रजिस्ट्रीज फाइव कौन-कौन से है भैया
एफ्रीकन
एरिन लकक एंड राइप एनसीसी इनमें फैले होते
हैं जो भी जो भी प्रोवाइडर्स होते हैं वह
आईपी रेंज जो एलोकेट करते हैं डिफरेंट
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन को वह एलोकेट करते हैं उन
कंपनीज को जब आईपी ब्लॉक बाय करनी होती है
तो इन्हीं से बाय करनी होती है यह जो
प्रोवाइडर्स है इनसे बाय करनी होती है जो
भी आपके प्रोवाइडर्स हैं जो आईपी रेंज
आपको पब्लिक जो आईपी ब्लॉक आपको देती है
उनसे आपको आईपी ब्लॉक आपको आईपी खरीदनी
होती है या तो आप ब्लॉक खरीदो या आईपीस
खरीदो एंड इन इनके जो एड्रेस पूल है जो
आईपी एड्रेस का पूरा पूल है वो इन्हीं
पांच जो डायरेक्टरीज है ना आर आईआरएस
रीजनल इंटरनेट रजिस्ट्रीज इन्हीं में फैले
होते हैं इन्हीं में होते हैं तो एसएन
नंबर क्या होता है ऑटोनोमस सिस्टम नंबर बस
आईपी एड्रेस के कलेक्शन को रिप्रेजेंट
करने का एंड कौन उसको ओन करता है उसका एक
तरीका है बट मैंने पहले ही बताया कि
छोटे-मोटे कंपनीज का कोई सीआईडीआर नहीं
होगा कोई नेटवर्क पूल नहीं होगा आईपी पूल
नहीं होगी नॉर्मल सी सर्वर्स पे आप व काम
कर रहे होंगे एंड या तो वह आईएसपी वगैरह
का यूज कर रहे होंगे या खुद का एक सर्वर
पे होस्ट कर रहे होंगे बड़ी कंपनी में
आपको आईपी पूल मिल जाती है अब यह क्यों
इंपॉर्टेंट है आपको पता है हम अब हम समझते
हैं कि हमें क्या-क्या चाहिए क्या-क्या
चाहिए हमें एक पर्टिकुलर टारगेट के लिए
चलिए हम अपना टारगेट डिसाइड करते हैं एंड
वी आर गोइंग टू अ गोइंग टू यूज द टारगेट
facebook.com लिस्ट में से एक
facebook.com निकाल लेते हैं आप
क को आज के टारगेट के लिए रखते हैं जिस
परे हम हंट करेंगे रेकन करेंगे एंड हम
इसलिए करेंगे क्योंकि
facebook.com बग बाउटी प्रोग्राम तो यह
मैं आपको दिखा भी देता हूं अगर आप सर्च
करेंगे
यहां पे इस तरीके से एंड अगर आप आप नीचे
आएंगे तो यहां पे आपके स्कोप मिल जाएंगे
क्या-क्या स्कोप के अंदर इनके कवर्ड हैं
कौन-कौन से इनके सर्विसेस कवर्ड हैं एंड
किस तरह के एलिजिबल वेबसाइट्स इसके अंदर
कवर्ड होते हैं इनएलिजिबल कौन से हैं ये
सारी चीजें आपको यहां पर लिस्ट मिल जाती
है तो यू हैव गट द परमिशन चलिए
अब
अब जब हम जब हम डोमस को क्लासिफाई करते
हैं तो दो तरह के क्लासिफिकेशन होते हैं
एक हॉरिजॉन्टल कोरिले होता है एक वर्टिकल
कोरिले होता है तो अब देखिए हॉरिजॉन्टल को
रिलेशन क्या होता है वर्टिकल कोरिले क्या
होता है एंड ये कितना इंपॉर्टेंट है ठीक
है यहां आपको ग्राफ दिख रहा होगा यानी कि
यहां पे आपको एक फोटो दिख रही होगी ठीक है
इस फोटो से मैं आपको थोड़ा समझाता हूं कि
व्हाट इज हॉरिजॉन्टल कोरिले ऑफ डोमेंस एंड
वर्टिकल कोरिले ऑफ डोमेंस तो यहां पे
हॉरिजॉन्टल का मतलब होता है इस तरीके से
वर्टिकल ये हो गया अब हॉरिजॉन्टल का मतलब
क्या होता है यह देखिए जैसे facebook.com
है ठीक है या फिर google.com है ठीक है अब
इनके जो डिफरेंट अदर डोमस होंगे ना
facebook.com के मान लो मैं हॉरिजॉन्टल की
बात करता हूं हॉरिजॉन्टल
की तो इनके दूसरे एक्वायर्ड डोमेंस या जो
भी दूसरे डोमेंस है वह हॉरिजॉन्टल कोरिले
डोमेंस कहलाते हैं जैसे मान लो मैं यहां
पे बात करता हूं instagram.com की
दिस इज दिस इज हॉरिजॉन्टल को रिलेशन दिस
इज हॉरिजॉन्टल डोमेंस जो लिस्ट है यह है
मैं बात करता हूं whatsapp.com की यह
में जितने भी उसके एक्वायर्ड या जो भी
डिफरेंट डोमेंस है ना व आपके हॉरिजॉन्टल
में आ जाते हैं ठीक है जो भी या फिर आप
इसको बोल दीजिए इस इनको हम एक्यूजेशंस में
ही रख लेते हैं मान लो इनको एक्यूजेशंस
में रखते हैं तो क्या है
facebook.com आपका कहलाएगा आपका
facebook.in ठीक है आपका
लेट्स सपोज अगर
google.com ठीक है आप इसमें
instagram.com भी इंक्लूड कर लो आप इसमें
इंक्लूड कर लो whatsapp.com ठीक है अब
google.com इज द हॉरिजॉन्टल डोमेन उसके
बाद हम बात करें blogger.com इज द हटल
हॉरिजॉन्टल डोमेन youtube.com ये हो गया
आपका ठीक है तो इस तरीके से ये काम करते
हैं हॉरिजॉन्टल डोमेन का मतलब यह होता है
ये सब डोमस कहलाते तो है हॉरिजॉन्टल सब
डोमेन बट ये एक दूसरे एक्विजिशन या किसी
दूसरे कंट्री स्पेसिफिक या कोई और डोमेन
होते हैं जो ग के ही अंदर आते हैं वही
होते हैं हॉरिजॉन्टल यह तो आपको समझ में आ
गया होगा दिस यू हैव अंडरस्टूड
राइट ये आपको समझ में आ गया होगा चलिए ये
हॉरिजॉन्टल हो गया अब वर्टिकल की बात कर
लेते हैं तो वर्टिकल में वह आते हैं जो
एक्चुअल सब डोमेन होते हैं यानी कि जैसे
कि बॉ
facebook.com जो उस पर्टिकुलर वेबसाइट के
अंदर में आते हैं तो blog.com यह हो गया
हेल्प facebook.com यह आपका वर्टिकल सब
डोमेन हो गए उसके बाद आपका अ
a.b. facebook.com सेकंड लेवल वाला यह भी
आपका वर्टिकल सब डोमेन हो गया तो आपको समझ
में अब आ चुका होगा तो हमें यह दोनों ही
गैदर करने
हैं यस यस यस माइक्रोसॉफ्ट का आप bing.com
ले लो बिल्कुल बिल्कुल उसका ये हॉरिजॉन्टल
है तो हमें एक टारगेट का ये दोनों ही
कलेक्ट करना है जितनी ज्यादा कलेक्ट कर
सकते हैं करेंगे हॉरिजॉन्टल वाले भी
करेंगे फिर उनका भी वर्टिकल करेंगे समझ
में आ रहा है पहले एक विजुलाइज करो आंखें
बंद सभी लोग आंखें बंद विजुलाइज करना क्या
है एक टारगेट है facebook.com उसका एक
टारगेट है उसका एक वर्टिकल भी और एक
हॉरिजॉन्टल भी हॉरिजॉन्टल से हमने जितने
भी एक्विजिशंस है हमने जितने भी अदर
डोमेंस है उनको उठा लिया ठीक है और
वर्टिकल से हमने
facebook's निकाले अब ये सब डोमेन और
हॉरिजॉन्टल के सब डोमेन फिर उनके सब डोमेन
के सब डोमेन फिर वर्टिकल के भी सब डोमेन
के सब डोमेन के सब डोमेन ये सब सब डोमेन
मिला के एक लिस्ट बनेगी सब डोमेन की जो कि
होगी हजारों में
समझ में आ रहा है हजारों में 200 हज 25000
300 अब उनमें एक शॉटिंग कर देंगे मतलब जो
भी यूनिक सब डोमेंस है जो बार-बार अगर
रिपीट हुए उनको हटा देंगे उसके बाद उसमें
हम लाइव सब डोमेंस को फिल्टर करेंगे कि
इतने सब डोमस में से लाइव कौन है जो अभी
चल रहा है भाई एंड देन हमारा एक फाइनल
लिस्ट तैयार होगा एक फाइनल सब डोमेन की
लिस्ट जिसपे हम फर्द हंट करना शुरू करेंगे
हम फर्द फिंगर प्रिंटिंग स्टार्ट करेंगे
अपना फिंगर प्रिंटिंग
फुट प्रिंटिंग आप पहले कर चुके होंगे
बेसिकली हम न्यूमरेशन स्टार्ट करेंगे उस
लिस्ट गट इट यह समझ में आ
गया समझ में आ गय यह गट इट एवरीवन गट इट
इसके बारे में चलिए इतना समझ में आया
चलिए अब हमने एक टारगेट ले लिया हमने एक
टारगेट ले लिया है वी हैव द टारगेट कौन सा
टारगेट है भैया facebook.com facebook.com
हम उसमें वर्टिकल एंड हॉरिजॉन्टल जो भी
डोमेंस है उन सबको फाइंड करने वाले हैं
जितने मिल सकते हैं फाइंड करने वाले हैं
तो चलिए सबसे पहले बात करते हैं कि
हमें हॉरिजॉन्टल को रिलेशन डोमेंस या उसके
बारे में और ज्यादा डिटेल्स कहां से
मिलेंगी अब मुझे चाहिए मेरा टारगेट है
facebook.com
गट इट मेरा टारगेट है facebook.com मुझे
पहले क्या करना है
हॉरिजॉन्टल डोमेंस फाइंड करने फिर वर्टिकल
सब डोमेंस फाइंड करने है इसको भी सब डोमन
लिख लो कोई दिक्कत नहीं है सब डोमन लिख लो
ठीक है हॉरिजॉन्टल सब डोमस वर्टिकल सब
डोमस फाइंड करने हैं उसके बाद आईपी
ब्लॉक्स फाइंड करनी है
मुझे आईपी ब्लॉक्स कितने सारे आईपी
एड्रेसस है इस पर्टिकुलर
टारगेट के पास क्योंकि हम आईपी पर भी तो
हंट करेंगे हम आईपी को भी तो न्यूमेट
करेंगे एन मैप करेंगे स्कैन करेंगे तो
आईपी तो
चाहिए हम सारे एक्विजिशंस फाइंड
करेंगे हम सारे डाटा निकालेंगे अब इसके
करने के बहुत अलग-अलग
तरीके चलिए तो हम स्टार्ट करते
हैं हम अपना
रिकॉर्न स्टार्ट करते हैं सबसे पहले यहां
पे हम क्या फाइंड करने की कोशिश करेंगे हम
आईपी ब्लॉक को फाइंड करने की कोशिश करेंगे
फर्स्ट ऑफ ऑल वी विल ट्राई टू फाइंड आईपी
ब्लॉक अब आईपी ब्लॉक को फाइंड करने के लिए
नेटवर्क ब्लॉक यानी कि एक कंपनी के पास एक
बड़ी कंपनी के पास कितनी बड़ी आईपी रेंज
है हमें आईपी पे भी यार हंट करना है वी
विल हंट ऑन आईपी एड्रेस हमें डोमेन भी
चाहिए सब डोमेन भी चाहिए आईपी एड्रेस भी
चाहिए तब हमारा जाके पूरा होता है एक
प्रॉपर रेकन एक किसी टारगेट पे तो अब आईपी
एड्रेस वो जो फाइंड करना है वह कैसे
मिलेगा व कहां से मिलेगा तो उसके लिए आईपी
ब्लॉक्स फाइंड करने के लिए आपको मल्टीपल
कुछ तरीके में बता रहा हूं सबसे पहले आपको
जाना है इस वेबसाइट पर मेरे पास
जो बुकमार्क है मैं पहले उसमें चलता हूं
एंड यहां पर हमारे पास एक एक वेबसाइट है
अरीन हुइज यह वेबसाइट है अरीन हुइज यह
सर्च करना आपको यह हु इज का रेस्टफुल वेब
सर्विस जो है उसका एक डायरेक्टरी है आप
बोल सकते हैं इस पर आपको आ जाना है यू हैव
टू कम
यर यहां आके जो भी आपका टारगेट है अगर कोई
बड़ी कंपनी है उसको सर्च करना है यू हैव
टू
सर्च क्या यहां बोल रहे हो लेक्चर
स्लाइड्स लेक्चर स्लाइड चलो अब यहां पर
आपको उस बड़ी कंपनी को सर्च करना है जैसे
मैं फ सर्च करता हूं एंड यहां पर एंटर कर
देता हूं फ एंटर करूंगा सर्च करके तो यहां
पर आपको कुछ रिजल्ट्स मिलेंगे अब इसको
मल्टीपल तरीके से आप एजीक्यू कर सकते हो
एक तो आप हरीन अरीन हु प आ गए यह एक आपका
लोकेशन है एक आपका मतलब जगह है यह करने का
यहां पर आप आओगे तो यहां पर आपको आईपी
एड्रेसस के पूल मिलेंगे यह देखो यहां पर
यू आर गेटिंग आईपी एड्रेसस पूल यह सारे
आईपी एड्रेसस फ के द्वारा ऑन किए जाते हैं
यह सारे आई य देखो यह सारे तुम्ह बिलीव
नहीं होगा यह कितने सारे आईपी ड्रेसेस है
यह सारे
आईड और यहां आपको फ का एक एस नंबर बताएगा
यानी एएसएन क्या है 32
934 क्या है 32 934 याद रखिएगा 32 934
बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट है जब आप इस पर क्लिक
करेंगे तो आपको
और भी आपको लिंक्स मिल जाएंगे अब यहां पर
आपको यह सारे आईपी रेंजेस ल् हेल्ड बाय फ
सारे के
सारे अब मुझे यह तो आईपी ब्लॉक्स हो गए अब
मुझे इनका सी आईडिया रेंज भी फाइंड करना
है कितने सी आईडिया रेंज यह कंडक्ट करते
हैं इसके मल्टीपल तरीके हैं एक आप एमस टूल
बॉक्स नाम की टूल यूज कर सकते हो यू कैन
यूज च टूल एमस टूल बॉक्स एम एकस टूल बॉक्स
इस वेबसाइट पर आ जाइएगा बहुत अच्छी
वेबसाइट है बहुत बढ़िया वेबसाइट है आप इस
पर आ जाइए यहां आएंगे ठीक है ए टूल बॉक्स
में तो यहां सुपर टूल का ऑप्शन आएगा आप इस
पर आ जाइए सुपर टूल प सुपर टूल प आप आएंगे
तो यहां पर मल्टीपल ऑप्शंस आपको दिखेंगे
टूल्स के लिस्ट में इसमें आके आपको
सेलेक्ट करना है एसएन एसएन वाली जो ऑप्शन
है वो सेलेक्ट कीजिए चलिए एसएन लुक अप इस
पर आ जाइए अब इसम आने प आपको यहां पर क्या
डालना है एसएन नंबर डालना है कौन सा एसए
नंबर डालना है भाई 329 34 329 34 यह वाला
नंबर फ का चलिए हमने डाल दिया 32 9 34 हम
य एस लुक अप करते हैं
एंड एंटर कर देते हैं जब हम एसन नंबर यहां
एंटर करेंगे 32 934 तो यह फब का एसन नंबर
है आप सबको पता होना चाहिए यह इसकी सी
आईडिया रेंज दे देगा सारे सी आईडिया रेंज
यह देखिए कितने सारे सी आईडिया रेंज आपको
दे रहा है यह देखो
भाई इतनी सारी सी आईडिया रेंज दे रहा है
अब तुम्हें देख के लग रहा होगा यह क्या है
सी आईडिया यह क्या हो हो रहा है ये सीआईडी
रेंज इससे क्या हमें कित अब इस सीआइडिया
रेंज में सारी आईपी एड्रेसस हैं जो
आने आएंगे ही ऐड
रुक जाता हूं वहां पे कुछ इंपॉर्टेंट नहीं
हो रहा होता है ठीक
है
चलिए हितेश इ सेइंग
5146 4 चलिए इन्होंने तो एक डाटा दे दिया
बट अब यहां पे हमारे पास एक सीआईडी रेंज
है अब चलिए हम देखते हैं इसमें कितनी आईपी
एड्रेस क्या-क्या कैसे हैं अब आपको
सीआइडिया रेंज के अंदर की आईपी पूल को
फाइंड करनी है तो देयर इज अ टूल उस पे हम
चलते हैं कौन सा टूल है मैं यहां पे एक
अपने टूल पे चलता हूं जिसका नाम है i
एड्रेस guide.com ये एक वेबसाइट है आप
यहां पे आ जाए
यहां आएंगे तो यहां पर सीआईडीआर टू आईपी
रेंज का एक टूल है एक वेब एप्लीकेशन है
यहां पर आपको सीआईडीआर पेस्ट करनी है जो
आपको मिली है चलिए मैं आपका पहला सीआईडीआर
यहां पे कॉपी कर लेता हूं एंड यहां पे कर
देता हूं पेस्ट यह हमने पहला सीआईडीआर
पेस्ट कर दिया ठीक है अब यहां कैलकुलेट प
क्लिक करते हैं जैसे ही कैलकुलेट प क्लिक
करेंगे नीचे आएंगे तो आपको दिखेगा यहां पे
कि सीआईडी रेंज जो हमने पेस्ट किया था
इसका नेट मास्क यह है एंड इसकी फर्स्ट
आईपी जो है वो हमारी यह है 31
1.24.0 एंड इसकी लास्ट आईपी यह है
31.1.18 इसमें
2048 आईपी एड्रेसस हैं इस रेंज में यानी
एक आई एक सीआईडीआर में 2048 आईपी रेंजेस
हैं आईपीस हैं यह
मार सकते हो कैसे भैया हमारा एंग्री आईपी
स्कैनर कब काम आएगा एंग्री आईपी स्कैनर कब
काम आएगा हमारे एंग्री आईपी स्कैनर को ओपन
करेंगे मतलब यह तो मैंने ये जो मैं बता
रहा हूं ये एंग्री आईपी स्कैनर आप ए मैप
का यूज कर सकते हैं ज्यादा बढ़िया होगा
मेरे ख्याल से या अदर एन मैप एनएससी
स्क्रिप्ट्स का भी उसमें आप डाल सकते हैं
रिकन के बट हम इसमें भी डाल सकते हैं भैया
तो हम आईपी रेंज डाल देंगे यहां पे फर्स्ट
आईपी ये वाली एंग्री आईपी स्कैनर जो हमारा
सॉफ्टवेयर
है ग कीजिएगा एंग्री आईपी स्कैनर आपको मिल
जाएगी एंड यहां पे लास्ट जो है यह वाली
हमारी यह वाली डाल देंगे एंग्री आईपी
स्कैनर
में आईपी रेंज हमने डाल दिया ठीक है और हम
यहां पे स्टार्ट कर देंगे ये एक जनरिक जो
है स्कैनिंग स्टार्ट कर देगा एंड ये हमें
बताएगा कौन सी आईपी पे अ कौन से अगर पोर्ट
कोई ओपन है या कोई ऐसा पोर्ट जो बिल्कुल
ओपन है एंड आपको मिल जाए शायद वहां पे
शायद कोई सर्विस आपको मिल जाए शायद कुछ
इंटरेस्टिंग मिल जाए एंड यू कैन रिपोर्ट
टू द
ये चीज पाई गई है ये वले एबिलिटी है ये
आपको मैं रिपोर्ट करता हूं ठीक है तो अभी
यहां पे आप देख सकते हो ये अभी भी स्कैन
हो रहा है 2000 आईपी एड्रेसस है समझ में आ
रहा है कितने इंटरेस्टिंग चीज है 2000 अभी
तो ये छोटी-मोटी चीज मैंने कर दी अब यहां
पे बैक करता हूं मैं फिर से अब फिर से
सीआई रेंज पे चलते हैं भैया अब यहां पे ना
एक ये वाली सीआई रेंज चलो ये वाली उठाते
हैं थर्ड वाली इसको कॉपी करते हैं एंड वी
आर गोइंग इन दिस अगेन एंड लेट्स पे स्टेट
एंड लेट्स सी हाउ मेनी आईपी एड्रेस वी आर
गेटिंग इन दिस हियर 256 इसमें ज्यादा नहीं
है 256 आईपी एड्रेस हैं ओनली यहां पे और
भी यहां पे आपके सीआईडी रेंज है इन सब पे
आप जो आईपी एड्रेसस हैं उसको निकाल सकते
हैं जितने भी आईपी एड्रेसस है उसको
निकालिए जैसे मान लो यह वाली आईपी एड्रेस
यह वाली सीआईडीआर ले लेते हैं यहां पे
चलते हैं एंड यहां पे पेस्ट करते हैं
सीआईडीआर को कैलकुलेट करते हैं इसमें आते
हैं इसमें भी 256 है अब यहां पे ये जो चीज
हमने कर ली अब हम यहां पे जो हमारा ये
वेबसाइट है अरीन हुज अरेन हुज यहां पे आप
आ चुके हैं यहां पे अब एक और वेबसाइट है
हमारा सेम चीज के लिए हम उस पर भी ट्राई
आउट कर सकते हैं च च आईपी च वेबसाइट मैं
फिर से इस पर चलता हूं एंड दिस वेबसाइट इज
वन बीजी प यह
वाली बीजप
एडनेट ठीक है आप यहां पर भी आ सकते हैं
एंड बेसिकली यहां आके यू कैन
लिटरली टाइप द एसएन
नंबर ये वाली 32 934 3293 4n नंबर डाला
ये वाली जो एसएन है ये कजें कम्युनिकेशंस
कनेक्टेड ये वाली एसएन है ये एलियोन स्वेन
एी कनेक्टेड ये वाली एसएन है एनटीटी
अमेरिका आईसी कनेक्टेड ये सारी आपको यहां
पे मिल जाती है अब यहां पे मैं अगर सर्च
करूं
facebook.com यहां पे एंटर किया तो अब
मुझे
र मिल रही है ये दिख र है
तुम्हें गेटिंग अ लॉट अ लॉट ऑफ सी आईडिया
रेंजेस जिसको आप आईपी एड्रेसस पूल जिसके
अंदर से जाके आप आईपी ड्रेसेस पूल निकाल
सकते हैं एंड यू विल गेट टू नो अ लॉट ऑफ
थिंग्स आपको पूरी आईपी एड्रेस की पूल यहां
पे मिल जाती है लॉट लॉट ऑफ यहां पे आपको
अब इस आईपी पूल में आप देखो भैया कौन सी
आईपी पूल में क्या है कितने आईपीस है ये
ट्राई मारो जैसे अब ये एक आईपी पूल है तो
चलो आ जाओ यहां से आईपी निकालो कहां गई
हमारी आईपी पूल वाली ये अ ये वाली यहां से
हमने किया हमने यहां से कैलकुलेट किया वी
विल गेट टू 1024 यहां 1024 आईपी एड्रेसस
है तो हमने यहां से 1024 आईपी ड्रेस निकाल
लि है ये फर्स्ट और ये लास्ट आईपी नोट कर
ली इसके अंदर की जितनी भी आईपी डस हैं
सारे आपके इसमें इंक्लूडेड है ठीक है तो
एक तो ये हो गया हमारा उसके बाद हमारे पास
मान लो ये वाली आईपी पूल है इसको भी हमने
यहां से कॉपी किया यहां पे सेड रेंज में
डाला कैलकुलेट किया और यहां पे 256 होस्ट
यहां पे हमारे आ चुके हैं ठीक है तो यू
विल गेट अ लॉट ऑफ सीआइडिया रेंजेस जिसको
आप आप आईपी एड्रेसस पूल के कन्वर्ट कर
सकते हैं इस टूल से आईपी एड्रेस गाइड से
एंड आईपी एड्रेसस को आप कलेक्ट कर सकते
हैं अब आपको यह तो समझ में आ गया कि आप
किसी एक होस्ट के किसी टारगेट के आईपी
एड्रेस की पूरी पूल कैसे आप निकाल सकते हो
एवरीवन गट इट मुझे बता
दीजिए मुझे बता दीजिए
जल्दी एवन गेट
इट
बताइए
मुझे यह आपको सब कुछ समझ में आ रहा है ना
किस तरीके से आप आईपी पूल निकाल सकते हैं
बहुत इजी
है ओके नॉट द टफ वन राइट कोई टफ नहीं है
ये
राइट चलिए अब यहां पे आप आईपी एड्रेस अब
मान लो मुझे
facebook.com मैं यहां पे अभी हम लोग क्या
कर रहे हैं
हमें क्या चाहिए आईपी वर्जन 4 चाहिए तो
पिं के बाद हान 4 लगा देंगे एंड एंटर
करेंगे हमें एक आईपी एड्रेस मिल जाएगी जो
एंड यहां पर चलते हैं एंड यहां प इसको
पेस्ट करते हैं कैलकुलेट करते हैं कितने
आईपी एड्रेसस हैं लेट्स सी 256 आईपी
एड्रेसस है बढ़िया अब इस वाले आईपी रेंज
को आईपी सीआईडीआर को कॉपी किया और इसमें
कैलकुलेट किया कि इसमें कितने आईपी एड्रेस
हैं यहां नीचे करेंगे और यहां देखो यहां
32768 आईपी एड्रेसस आर देयर इन दिस सीआईडी
रेंज ये तुम समझ रहे हो ना एक सीआईडी रेंज
में 32768 आईपी एड्रेसस होल्ड करता है
कहां से कहां भैया यहां से लेके यहां तक
की आईपी एड्रेस
ठीक
है 32768 आईपी है भाई छोटी मोटी बात नहीं
है इतनी आईपी एड्रेस मिल गई आप इस पे करते
रहो ना आप इसपे एन मैप करो इसपे आप मास्क
स्कैन करो आप इस परे अलग-अलग तरह की
स्कैनिंग करते रहो एंड यहां आईपी स्कैनर
में लगा दो यह देखो यहां पे आ रही है
होस्ट स्कैन हुई है 2032 आईपी जिसमें 297
होस्ट अलाइव है ओपन पोर्ट्स के साथ शायद
कोई भी होस्ट आपको यहां पे नहीं देखने को
मिलेगा ओपन पोर्ट वाले होते तो ग्रीन कलर
में आ जाता नेक्स्ट ओपन पोर्ट्स पे चलेंगे
शायद कोई भी नहीं है ओपन पोर्ट कोई सा भी
नहीं है कुछ पोर्ट्स हैं अलाइव वाले जो
हैं वो है बस ओनली बट ओपन नहीं है अगर ओपन
रहते तो फिर तो क्या ही बात होती है आप
यहां पे देख सकते हैं यहां पे तो ये आईपी
अड्रेस रीचे बल है एंड यहां पे कॉपी आईपी
दे यहां पे कॉपी आईपी या फिर ओपन कर लो
इसको ओपन अ वेब ब्राउजर में तो यहां से
ओपन होगा ये आईपी पर्टिकुलर ली जो भी
होस्ट नेम है यहां से यह ओपन हो जाएगी एंड
यहां पे कुछ है तो मिल जाएगा फरदर आप इस
पे डायरेक्टरी ब्रूट फोर्सिंग वगैरह हम
करेंगे ज बाद में देखेंगे या कोई
स्क्रिप्ट वगैरह चला के कोई वलने एबिलिटी
या कुछ ऐसा है इस पे कुछ ऐसा कंटेंट है
कुछ ऐसा है तो वो हम फाइंड करेंगे तो इतने
सारे आईपी एड्रेस होल्ड करता है तो ये
हमारी आईपी ब्लॉक्स फाइंड करने के तरीके
हो गए किससे आईपी एड्रेस गाइड से आप
सीआईडीआर को आईपी में कन्वर्ट कर सकते हैं
बी बीजीपी e.net से भी आप फाइंड कर सकते
हैं उसके बाद मैंने आपको एक और टूल बताया
mx2 बॉक्स आप इससे भी कर सकते हैं इसके
अलावा एक और टूल है आप उससे भी कुछ चीजें
पता कर सकते हैं कुछ क्या या बहुत कुछ पता
कर सकते हो व्यू डीएनएस इंफो नेक्स्ट टूल
आप अपने आर्सनल में अपने बग बाउंट आर्सनल
में इस टूल का लिस्ट में नाम डाल लीजिए
इसको इसको आप लिस्ट कर लीजिए लिख लीजिए
कहीं v dso138
लिए आप इसका यूज बहुत अच्छे से कर सकते
हैं बहुत इंटरेस्टिंग चीज है कैसे करेंगे
भाई यह चीज हम अभी देखेंगे बट इसमें भी
आपको एसन लुकअप मिलता है एंड यहां पे भी
आप
के लिए आप मल्टीपल जैसे किसी भी डोमेन के
बारे में पूरी डिटेल चाहिए तो उसकी हु इज
डाटा हम देखते हैं ठीक है हु इज डाटा
देखने के लिए आप हु इज किसी भी हु इज
पोर्टल पे जा सकते हैं हु इज लाइक ड आ यह
बहुत पॉपुलर है इस पे भी जा सकते हैं यहां
आप सर्च करेंगे
facebook.com तो आपको उसकी डोमेन की पूरी
डिटेल देगा नेम हु इ सर्वर कौन सा है
एक्सपायर कब हुआ है कब अपडेट हुआ वो
पर्टिकुलर डोमेन नेम सर्वर्स कौन-कौन से
हैं एंड उनकी पूरी ये डिटेल देगा अब इस
डिटेल में गाइस या फिर हम यहां पर आते हैं
तो आपको एक ईमेल आईडी मिल रही है कौन सी
ईमेल आईडी मिल रही है यहां पर आप देखो
नीचे आ जाओ वी गट एन ईमेल एड्रेस कहां गया
ईमेल
एड्रेस यह यह एक ईमेल आईडी मिल गई टेक
ईमेल डन @ facebook.com
य एक ईमेल आईडी मिलया अब यह ईमेल आईडी अब
देखो मैं आपसे एक सवाल पूछता हूं मान लो
आपकी कंपनी है आपने क का एक ईमेल आईडी
बनाया मेरे कंपनी है जैसे मेरी कंपनी है
ठीक है फ्रक्स डेनिक्स पे आप नीचे आएंगे
तो आपको एक ईमेल आईडी मिलेगी यहां पे
कांटेक्ट करने का कांटेक्ट पे चलिए यहां
पे आप नीचे आएंगे तो आपको एक ईमेल आईडी
मिलेगी
@com ये मेरी कंपनी की डोमेन की ईमेल आईडी
है डोमेन ईमेल आईडी अब यह ईमेल आईडी और भी
किसी और ऐसी वेबसाइट पे है जो f.com नहीं
है मान लो कोई और भी कोई और वेबसाइट है
मान लो ए बीसी ए स df.com है उसपे भी आपको
कांटेक्ट में यही ईमेल आईडी मिली है या
मिल रही है तो आपको क्या लगेगा यही लगेगा
ना या ऐसा ही प्रोबेबिलिटी है ना कि वो
वेबसाइट भी मेरी ही होगी तभी मैंने खुद की
ईमेल आईडी वहां डाल रखी है राइट
प्रोबेबिलिटी तो यही है प्रोबेबिलिटी यही
है
ना प्रोबेबिलिटी यही है ना बता दीजिए
मुझे लेट मी नो एवरीवन प्लीज सभी लोग
बताइए इज दिस द सेम
प्रोबेबिलिटी कि वो वेबसाइट भी मेरी होगी
या मेरे द्वारा ओंड होगी तब तक मैं पानी
पी लेता हूं
ओके मेरे द्वारा ऑन होगी हु इज क्या होता
है हु इज एक डेटाबेस है जो एक किसी डोमेन
के बारे में पूरी डिटेल देता है उसके
रजिस्ट्रेशन की डिटेल जब आप कोई डोमेन
रजिस्टर करते हो तो जब वो रजिस्टर हो जाता
है तो उसके बाद आपका हु इज जो है वो आपको
बताता है उस डोमेन के बारे में सारी डिटेल
उस कंपनी के बारे में नेम सवर के बारे में
उसकी एड्रेस उसके कांटेक्ट उसके फोन नंबर
सारी कुछ देता है ठीक है चलिए तो हमने
क्या किया यह यहां से यह डोमेन यह ईमेल
आईडी जो इनकी है इसको उठा लिया @
facebook.com इसको उठा लिया इनकी ईमेल
आईडी है अब हम इस ईमेल आईडी से हम क्या
करेंगे तहलका मचाएंगे हम इस ईमेल आईडी से
रिवर्स हु इज लुक अप
करेंगे मतलब फाइंड ऑल डोमेन
ऑल डोमेन नेम्स ओंड बाय एन इंडिविजुअल और
कंपनी मतलब ऐसे सारे डोमेन नेम जो एक
कंपनी ओन करती है हम वो फाइंड करेंगे अब
यहां इंडिविजुअल अब यहां क्या दे रहा है
या तो आप रजिस्ट्रा नेम दीजिए या ईमेल
एड्रेस दीजिए तो आप यहां तो फब दे दीजिए फ
दे दीजिए फ आईसी दे दीजिए या ईमेल एड्रेस
डाल दीजिए हमारे पास ईमेल आईडी है ना यार
फ की तो हमने डाल दिया यहां पे डोमेन @
facebook.com यह हमने ईमेल आईडी डाल द
चलिए अब देखते हैं
मैंने गो पे क्लिक किया जैसे ही गो पे
क्लिक किया गाइ वी गॉट सम डिटेल्स हमने
जैसे ही गो पे क्लिक किया हमें कुछ डिटेल
मिली है क्या डिटेल मिली है रिवर्स होज लक
अप में हमें यहां पे 19 डोमस मिले हैं जो
इस पर्टिकुलर ईमेल आईडी को मैच करते हैं
क्यूस्ट facebook.com facebook.co
मिले हैं दिस आर ओंड बाय
facebook.com से आपने यह चीज फाइंड की अब
यहां पे रजिस्ट्रा नेम मैं मान लो यहां पे
जब मैंने
कौन करती है यह हॉरिजॉन्टल डोमेन की लिस्ट
हो
गई यह हॉरिजॉन्टल डोमेन लिस्ट हो गई वे फ
से ही रिलेटेड डोमेंस है सब डोमेंस नहीं
हम बोलेंगे इनको दिस आर एक्चुअल डोमेंस
एंड दिस आर रिलेटेड टू सम हाउ फ तो हमें
यही तो पता यही तो करना है यार एक टारगेट
एक टारगेट के रिलेटेड डोमेंस और उस
पर्टिकुलर टारगेट का ही सब डोमेन अब
रिलेटेड डोमेन के सब डोमस और पर्टिकुलर जो
बब साइट है जो टारगेट है उसके सब डोमेंस
के सब डोमेंस ऐसे फाइंड करते करते चलना है
पूरी ह्यूज लिस्ट बनानी है स्कोप को बड़ा
करना है टारगेट के लिए एंड देन हंट करना
है आपको वलने बिलिटी मिलेगी एंड आपको
वैलिड बग मिलेगा मैं आपको गारंटी देता हूं
ना फॉलो तो करो फॉलो तो करो यार अच्छे से
करो दिमाग टाइम दो पेशेंस रखो फॉलो करते
चलो नहीं मिली तो मेरे को बोलना और जिसको
पहली बाउंट जब भी जैसे भी मिले मुझे जरूर
टैग करना मुझे बताना जरूर भूल मत जाना ठीक
है चलिए तो यहां पे ये सारे डोमेंस
लिस्टेड है अब इनकी आप लिस्ट बनाइए
हॉरिजॉन्टल की लिस्ट बनाइए जैसे मेरे पास
यह डोमेन है मान
लो चलो यहां से मैं चलता हूं यह डोमेंस है
मैंने इन डोमस को कॉपी कर लिया यहां से
मान लो एंड इनकी एक लिस्ट बना
ली इनकी एक लिस्ट बना ली
दैट्ची बहुत इंटरेस्टिंग
है लसे कॉ ब आप इस वेबसाइट पे चलिए
lg.com यह एक ऑल इन वन वेबसाइट है बहुत
शानदार वेबसाइट है एक बहुत इंटरेस्टिंग
वेबसाइट है याद रखिएगा दिस इज अ वेरी वेरी
इंटरेस्टिंग वेबसाइट गाइ आप यहां पे आइए
आप यहां पे जब आप आएंगे गाइस तो यहां पे
आप आइए मान लो ओट पे आ जाते हैं अब जब ओट
पे आएंगे तो यहां पे आपको डोमेन डालना है
उस से रिलेटेड सारी जानकारी आपको मिलेगी
एवरी
facebook.com मुझे क्या करना है रिवर्स
आईपी या रिवर्स डोमेन यह करना है मान लो
रिवर्स डोमेन करना है मैं क्लिक करूंगा
एंड ये क्या करेगा मुझे उस पर्टिकुलर
रिसोर्स के पास लेके जाएगा वो थर्ड पार्टी
हो या कोई सी भी हो वहां से मुझे जो भी
लिस्ट है वो निकाल के देगा जैसे
facebook.com से रिलेटेड जितने यहां पे
रिवर्स आपको डोमस है वो आपको मिल जाएंगे
उसी तरीके से रिवर्स आईपी भी आपको करनी है
लुकअप आप उस पे क्लिक कीजिए एंड इसकी जो
पर्टिकुलर जो रिवर यहां पे कुछ इन्होंने
यहां पे कुछ डिटेक्शन करके यहां पे कुछ
दिए हैं बट डिटेक्शन हुई है बट कोई बात
नहीं यहां पे कुछ डोमेंस आपको रिवर्स आईपी
के थ्रू आपको मिल गई है एंड ये देखिए कब
के हैं ये लास्ट रिजॉल्व डेट 1970 1970 के
ओल्ड डेटा आपको मिल रहे हैं यहां पे बहुत
ओल्ड डाटा है ये देखिए आप यहां पे भी काफी
कुछ यूजफुल आपके लिए हो सकता है ठीक है
उसी तरीके से आईपी हिस्ट्रीज आईपी
हिस्ट्रीज पे जाएंगे तो पूरी की पूरी आईपी
हिस्ट्रीज आपको ये दिखाएगा उस पर्टिकुलर
डोमेन नेम के लिए एंड आपको लिस्ट करके दे
देगा तो पूरी की पूरी हर एक चीज ना आपको
ये यहां से दे देता है हु इज का हिस्ट्री
यहां पे आपको मिल जाएगा आपको यहां पे
यूआरएल स्कैन मिल जाएगा सब कुछ आपको मिल
जाएगी तो आप इसका भी यूज कर सकते हैं व्यू
डीएनएस का यूज आप कर सकते हैं इसका भी कर
सकते हैं डोमेन कलेक्ट करने के लिए अब
यहां पे एक और चीज है एंड उसको उस वेबसाइट
को हम बोलेंगे हुक सी हुक सी एच डब् एच ओ
एक्सवा हुक सी आप इसका भी यूज करेंगे
डोमेंस को फाइंड करने के लिए या पर्टिकुलर
बहुत सारी चीजें फाइंड करने के लिए आप कर
सकते हैं जैसे कि मान लो मेरे पास इनकी
हालांकि थोड़ी पेड सर्विस भी कुछ यूज ये
देते हैं ठीक है बट स्टिल फ्री में भी
बहुत कुछ है मान लो यहां पे एंटर ए डोमेन
नेम हु इज लुकअप के लिए facebook.com हमने
किया एंटर कर दिया जैसे ही हमने एंटर
किया आपको इससे रिलेटेड सारी डिटेल्स मिल
जाएंगी देखो यहां पे डोमेन रजिस्ट्रार जो
भी है ठीक है यहां पे यहां पे सारी
डिटेल्स मिल गई यहां नीचे आओगे तो यहां पे
कांटेक्ट मिल जाएगा डोमेन एडमिन मेटा
प्लेटफॉर्म्स ये एड्रेस मिल गई आपकी इनकी
ये ईमेल आईडी
domain.com ये आपको मिल गई
domain.com ये ईमेल आईडी है इसको मैंने
कॉपी ईमेल एड्रेस किया मैं यहां पे इसमें
आऊंगा अगेन यहां पे ना इस वाले पे रिवर्स
ईज करूंगा यहां पे गो पे क्लिक करूंगा
मुझे लिस्ट आपको मिल जाएगी देखो 5717 यह
पूरी लिस्ट मिल गई जो
facebook.com इन द पास्ट पास्ट में
facebook.com को किसने ऑन किया उसकी पूरी
डिटेल है भैया तो यह देखिए यहां पे सारी
चीजें यहां पे दे रखी है सारी डिटेल्स
यहां पे दे रखी है यह
देखो ये देखो ये पूरी डिटेल आपको दे रखी
है अब मुझे यहां पे हु इज लुक अप नहीं
करना मुझे यहां पे क्या करना है रिवर्स हु
इज करना है मान लो किसके थ्रू ईमेल एड्रेस
के थ्रू तो मैं यहां पे रिवर्स हु इज अ एक
ऐड आई है तो मैं इसको स्किप कर देता हूं अ
यहां पे और फिर मैं स्टार्ट करता हूं ठीक
है अब यहां पे ईमेल एड्रेस के थ्रू तो
ईमेल एड्रेस हमें पता है यहां पे सर्च
करेंगे तो ईमेल एड्रेस के थ्रू हमें पूरी
लिस्ट य यहां पे भी आपको मिल जाती है
देखिए यहां पे
917 15 डोमेन नेम्स जो डोमेन रेट
fb.com से कनेक्टेड है ये सारी डोमस की
लिस्ट आपको ये देखिए यहां मिली है लेकिन
इसमें से क्या है सिर्फ और सिर्फ 100
डिस्प्ले कर रहे हैं एंड बाकी के लिए भैया
आपको इनका एपीआई यूज करना है एपीआई यूज
करने के लिए आपको पैसे देने पड़ते हैं
बेसिकली कि आप देख सकते हैं 1000 हुज
लुकअप के लिए ल ले रहे हैं कम है इनका
1000 के लिए $5 ले रहे हैं 1000 के लिए
लिए ये $ से न्यूली लेजिस्ट के लिए इतना
है पूरा हु इसका डेटाबेस चाहिए आपको 520
मिलियन डोमस का तो 000 इनको देने पड़ेंगे
भैया $100 में पूरी हुज डेटाबेस से आप
खरीद सकते हो तो ये ठीक है जिनके पास पैसे
वो काम ये करते हैं बहुत लोगों ने लिया भी
हुआ है बट स्टिल हमें अभी इसकी
रिक्वायरमेंट नहीं है हमें अभी पर्टिकुलर
जितने डोमेंस निकाल सकते हैं जितने
पर्टिकुलर डोमेंस आप फाइंड कर सकते हैं
उतने हमें निकालने है ट्स इट इससे मतलब है
ठीक है और कुछ नहीं
चलिए
या रिलेटेड डोमेन इज इक्वल टू हॉरिजॉन्टल
डोमेन बहुत सर बहुत अच्छा पढ़ा रहे हो आप
की पिट अप थैंक यू निलेश भाई चलिए आप
पढ़ते रहिए और हम पढ़ाते रहेंगे कोई
दिक्कत नहीं है ठीक है तो आपके पास लिस्ट
हो गई कितनी सारी टूल्स की लिस्ट तैयार हो
गई भैया मैं आपको वह भी बता देता
हूं पहला हमने क्या बनाया हमने एक कौन सी
टूल देखी हमने एक अरीन हुइज देखा आईपी
ब्लॉक्स के लिए आईपी ब्लॉक्स के लिए यह
हमने देखा दूसरा हमने बीजीपी एई देखा आईपी
ब्लॉक्स
एसए ठीक है ईटीसी इन सब के लिए देखा तीसरा
हमने कौन सा देखा हमने कौन सी तीसरी वाली
वेबसाइट देखी व्यू डीएनएस इंफो व्यू
डीएनएस इंफो हमने इसको देखा चौथा हमने
हुक्स को भी देखा पांचवा हमने एमएक्स टूल
बॉक्स देखा एमएक्स टूल बॉक्स यह टूल हमने
यह इसको यूज किया छठा हमने ड आ को भी यूज
किया है तो हमने उसको भी मेंशन कर दिया
हमने इसके लिए यह सारी चीजें हमने अभी तक
फिलहाल देख लिए बहुत सारी चीजें देख ली
हमने वैसे तो ठीक
है चलिए यहां भी आप होज लुक अप कर सकते हो
यहां पे भी आप facebook.com ये भी एक
वेबसाइट है भैया facebook.com यहां भी
डाला एंड न tools.com यहां पे भी आएंगे और
यहां पे भी आपको डिटेल्स जो है वो मिल
जाएगी वेरिफिकेशन रिक्वायर्ड है ऐसी चीजों
को मैं वेरीफाई वेरीफाई नहीं करता और हां
हमने यह भी देखा हमने यह भी यूआरएल देख ली
इसको भी मैं कॉपी कर लेता हूं इसको भी
लिस्ट में डाल देता हू देता हूं ये क्यों
गुस्सा होगा सेवंथ में अ यह
वाला ठीक है लसक कब यह वाली भी हमने चीज
देखी है चलिए बहुत बढ़िया हमने इतनी सारी
चीजें कर ली हमने इतनी सारी चीजें देख ली
है चलिए तो यहां से आपको हॉरिजॉन्टल
डोमेंस के पूरी लिस्ट मिल गई आईपी ब्लॉक्स
मिल गया सब कुछ मिल गया ठीक है हॉरिजॉन्टल
एंड आईपी ब्लॉक्स दोनों मिल गए तो हमें
आ चुके फ के
टल डोमस भी हमारे पास लिस्ट आ चुकी
है अब हमें चाहिए एक्विजिशंस के भी
डिटेल्स एक्विजिशंस भी हमें चाहिए तो हमें
एक्विजिशंस का वैसे हमारे पास ऑलरेडी बग
बाउंट प्रोग्राम जो है
है आपका इनका एक्विजिशन है क्वेस्ट वर्क
प्लेस यह सारे आपको मिल जा रहे ठीक है बट
स्टिल आप क्या कर सकते हैं चट जीपीटी का
भी यूज कर सकते हैं चार जीपीटी प आइए चर
जीपीटी प आइए इनसे पूछिए हे चार जीपीटी हे
चारजी पीटी ऐसे नहीं पूछो ऐसे बो हे ऐसे
बोलते हे
आई वांट अ लिस्ट ऑफ
एक्विजिशन एक्विजिशंस
एसी स्पेलिंग थोड़ी मिस्टेक हुई एस क्य यू
आई एस आई टी आई एक्विजिशंस
बाय मेटा और
के जितने भी एकशन आपको बता देगा जैसे
instagram2 में हुए थे अक्वायर्ड बाय फ
फॉर 1 बिलियन डलर
ऑकुलस र 2014 लाइव रेल 2014 एसेंटा 2014
सीटीआर 2019 गिफी कस्टमर रेडी एट डॉन
यूनिट टू गेम्स मैलरी बीट गेम्स यह
एक्विजिशन से फ के अब इन एक्विजिशन के भी
हम डिटेल्स निकाले उनके भी हम फिर सब डोमस
डोमस नि निकालेंगे सब डोमेंस निकालेंगे सब
निकालेंगे समझ में आ रहा है ना भाई तुम जो
सोचते हो बग बाउंट का बग बाउंट इज अ वेरी
कॉम्प्लेक्टेड बग मिलेगा तुम्हें कोई
प्रॉब्लम नहीं आएगी सब कुछ मिलेगा ठीक है
तो यह
तुम्हें हितेश मेरी वेबसाइट प देखो बड़ी
टारगेट ट्राई करो मेरी वेबसाइट ट्राई
करोगे तो अभी ज्यादा कुछ मिलेगा नहीं
क्योंकि उसमें ज्यादा ना तो
आपको सब डोमस मिलेंगे ना आपको कोई
हॉरिजॉन्टल कुछ मिलेगा आपको तो इसलिए
ट्राई ऑन द बिग वेबसाइट ठीक है स्टार्टिंग
के लिए यह समझ में आ रहा है इतना सब कुछ
समझ में आ रहा
है
ओके चलिए तो यह एक्विजिशन आ गए अब यहां से
हमने एक्विजिशंस निकाल
लिए हमने क्या
किया यहां से हमने एक्यूजेशंस निकालिए
instagram's ठीक है हमारे पास आ गया
एक्विजिशंस तो हमारे पास बहुत सारी डिटेल
आ गई अभी तो आपको अभी तो समझ में अभी तो
अभी तो देखो अभी तो ये डोमेन का अलग ही
गेम है यह तो मैं ये तो सिर्फ हॉरिजॉन्टल
अभी बात कर रहे हैं हम वर्टिकल की तो बात
ही नहीं कर रहे अभी फिलहाल के लिए
तो हमारे पास हॉरिजॉन्टल आ गया यह डन
वर्टिकल नहीं हुआ आईपी ब्लॉक्स डन यह आ गए
एक्विजिशन डन अब हमारा बच गया वर्टिकल सब
डोमेंस वर्टिकल सब डोमेंस मैंने इसलिए अभी
नहीं लिया क्योंकि इस पर पूरी सेपरेट
क्लास चलेगी बड़ी लंबी सी थोड़ी मतलब सब
डोमेंस कैसे इनमेट करते हैं कैसे फाइंड
करते हैं इस पर पूरी क्लास चलेगी तो अभी
के लिए आपको क्या करना है आपको एक लिस्ट
बनानी है लिस्ट बनानी है मैं आपको एक
लिस्ट देता आपको मैं एक छोटा सा लिस्ट
देता हूं आपको मैं एक टास्क देता हूं सभी
लोग को करना है ठीक है नेक्स्ट जो भी
क्लास होगी उसके पहले अभी और भी चीज बाकी
अभी करानी है मुझे बतानी है अभी इस क्लास
में भागना नहीं है अभी आपको बट एक बीच में
आपको एक टास्क दे देता हूं सब लोग करके
आएंगे ना मुझे बता दीजिए
सॉरी पहला
टास्क पहला
टास्क आपको ट्राई हैक में प आ जाना है यू
हैव टू कम टू ट्रा हैक मी लर्न पर जाना
है
लन पर जाना
है लर्निंग पाथ मिलेगी लर्निंग पाथ प आना
है एंड यहां पर प्री सिक्योरिटी पाथ प आना
है प्री सिक्योरिटी इस पर आ जाना है प्री
सिक्योरिटी पर आने के बाद आपको इसको
कंप्लीट करना है इंट्रोडक्शन टू साइबर
सिक्योरिटी कंप्लीट करनी है नेटवर्क
फंडामेंटल्स इसकी लैब को कंप्लीट इसकी
वर्क थ्रू और लैब जो
है सॉल्व करना है हाउ द वेब वर्क्स इसको
सॉल्व करना है
वह इसी लाइव के डिस्क्रिप्शन में आपको सब
मिल जाएंगे उनमें से आप हैंडल्स को टैग कर
सकते हैं एंड देन हम उनको रीपोस्ट करेंगे
ठीक है यह पहला टास्क आपको कर लेना है
सबसे पहला
टास्क आपको कर लेनी है यह चीज़ प्री
सिक्योरिटी ठीक है पेड भी है अगर तो आपको
इसका सब्सक्रिप्शन लेना है मैं आपको पहले
ही बता चुका हूं कांटेक्ट कीजिए कहीं ना
कहीं आपको
ठीक है पहला आपका टास्क ये है दूसरा टास्क
ये
है टास्क टू क्या
है टास्क वन क्या था आपका ट्राई हैक मी
वाला था एंड टास्क टू क्या था
आपका टास्क टू ये है
आपका
कि चूज अ टारगेट चूज अ टारगेट वो कोई सा
भी टारगेट हो सकता है चाहे वो चूज अ
टारगेट कोई सा भी आप टारगेट चूज कर लीजिए
एफबी को कर लीजिए ग कर लीजिए टेस्ला को
यूज कर लीजिए
या फिर यू कैन
यूज अन आप इसको भी यूज कर सकते हैं य गो
फॉर अन या या राइजन मीडिया को भी आप कर
लीजिए कोई सा भी आप कर लीजिए ठीक है
माइक्रोसॉफ्ट कर लीजिए माइक्रोसॉफ्ट कर
लीजिए आप टारगेट चूज कीजिए एंड चूज टारगेट
एंड
गैदर
एवरी
एवरी डोमेन रिलेटेड टू ट टारगेट एव डोमस
मैं सब डोमेन के भी बात नहीं कर रहा एवरी
डोमेन डोमेन रिलेटेड टू द टारगेट रोमेंस
एंड आईपी एंड आईपी
एड्रेसस जितने भी डोमेंस है और जितनी आईपी
एड्रेसस है उस पर्टिकुलर टारगेट से
रिलेटेड यह
आपको एक लिस्ट बनानी है एंड लिस्ट बना के
लानी है एक ही टारगेट का उन कैसे क्याक
आएंगे आईपी ब्लॉक्स आईपी रेंजेस पूरी आईपी
एड्रेस आ जाएगी आपको पता दिया सब कुछ
हॉरिजॉन्टल डोमस आ जाएंगे सारे जो रिलेटेड
हैं और जो भी एक्विजिशन के डोमस है वो आ
जाएंगे इसकी लिस्ट बनानी है एक फाइल बनानी
है लिस्ट बना देंगे एंड ये टास्क कंप्लीट
आपको कर लेना है किसी भी हाल में ठीक
है
ओके सर एफबी का तो एक ही एसएन था बट अगर
एसन ज्यादा हुए तो एफबी का एक ही एसएन तो
नहीं है हां एफबी के अब एसए की बात करते
हैं हां एफबी का एक एसए है मान लो यहां पे
3934 अब यहां पे आपको कुछ और भी आपको मिल
जाएंगी एेंस की अगर बात करते हैं तो जब हम
यहां पे एस टूल बॉक्स को यूज कर रहे हैं ए
टूल बॉक्स कहां गई यहां
पे ये तो आपको एक ही एसए में बहुत सारे
यहां पे आपको आईपी रेंजेस मिलते हैं आप उन
आईपी रेंजेस को ही कलेक्ट कीजिए आईपी
एड्रेसस को कलेक्ट कीजिए बहुत सारे हो
जाते हैं मल्टीपल एसएन नंबर आपको अगर मिल
भी रहा है तो अलग-अलग कर कीजिए कोई दिक्कत
नहीं है लेकिन आपको एसएन जो होगा ना वो
ऑलमोस्ट मोस्टली आपको एक ही मिलेगा
मोस्टली आपको एक ही एस नंबर आपको मिलेगी
ठीक है तो यहां पे टोटल आईपी एड्रेस जो है
यहां पे जो उस टाइम पे एक बंदे ने बोला था
वही यह चीज है 5106 64 टोटल आईपी एड्रेस
कितने हैं इसके अंदर में
5146 4 आईपी एड्रेसस हैं एक पर्टिकुलर
एएसएन ऑटोनोमस सिस्टम के आईपी एड्रेस की
पूरी पूल है अब सोचो इसको स्कैन करोगे
इतने आईपी एड्रेस को क्यों नहीं मिलेगी
लेबिलिटी यार टाइम होना चाहिए फास्ट चीज
होनी चाहिए अब देखो वही यहीं पे आ जाती है
वीपीएस की यहीं पे वीपीएस का रोल आ जाता
है तुम सोचो खुद सोचो खुद सोचो यस मोस्टली
आपको
क यहां एंटर कर लेते हैं एंड यहां पे हमने
इसको कॉपी कर
लिया ठीक है अब हमने यहां पे यह आईपी
एड्रेस डाल दी हमने यहां पे सर्च कर लिया
google2 नंबर जो आपका मिलता है हम इसको
कॉपी कर लेंगे एंड इसकी जो रेंज है वो
फाइंड कर लेंगे ठीक है इसकी रेंज हम फाइंड
करके देखेंगे कितने आईपी एड्रेस फिलहाल ये
होल्ड करता है एंड यहां पे मिलेगी
65536 आईपी एड्रेसस ये होल्ड करता है अगर
आप सिमिलर सेम अगर आप ए टूल बॉक्स प जाते
हैं एंड यहां पे आप एस नंबर डाल देते
11 लाख है क्या कितने है नहीं नहीं 11 लाख
कहां है न
करोड़ ये देखो 1 करोड़ 16
9324 आईपी एड्रेसस ग के है भाई ये सोचो ग
का क्या नेटवर्क इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर है
इमेजिन करोना ग का नेटवर्क
इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर कैसा है किस तरीके का किस
लेवल का
है समझ में आ रहा
है ठीक है ठीक है गॉट
इट गॉट इट इतने आईपी एड्रेसस ग प तो आप ये
फाइंड कर सकते हो तो आपको मैंने सारा कुछ
बता दिया आपको मैंने क्या
बताया व्हाट आई टोल्ड आपको मैंने
हॉरिजॉन्टल कॉरिलेशन बताया हुसी व्यू
डीएनएस एंड और भी बहुत सारे टूल्स बताए
मैंने आपको ठीक है जिससे कि आपको ये चीजें
फाइंड करनी है अरेन हु इ से आईपी ब्लॉक्स
फाइंड करने हैं आपको बीजीपी एई से आप आईपी
ब्लॉक्स उसके रेंजेस फाइंड कर सकते हैं
एंड हां एक और था आईपी एड्रेस गाइड आईपी
एड्रेस गाइड से सी आईडिया रेंज सी आईडिया
टू आईपी कन्वर्ट कर सकते हैं यह कर दिया
व्यू डीएन बताया हुसी बताया टूल बॉक्स
बताया ई बताया l.com बता दिया आ गाइड से
भी बताया ये सारे टूल्स अपने आप में बहुत
इंटरेस्टिंग टूल्स है चलिए हम साइड में
काली को भी स्टार्ट कर लेते हैं क्योंकि
काली प हम कुछ करने वाले हैं एंड लेट्स
स्टार्ट
काली लेट्स बूट काली एंड लेट्स वेट बहुत
इंपॉर्टेंट है गाइस यह सेशन बहुत बहुत
इंपोर्टेंट है याद रखिएगा हमने ये
हॉरिजॉन्टल एंड बाकी रिलेटेड सब डोमेन
डोमेंस निकाले हैं हम ऐसे बहुत सारी चीजें
और भी निकाल सकते हैं
आप फाइंड करते हो उसकी फिर सीआईडीआर रेंज
फाइंड करते हो डोमेन से आप सब डोमस फाइंड
करते हो डोमेन से आप सब डोमेंस फाइंड करते
हो फिर सब डोमेंस पे आप फर्द दूसरी जो
स्टेप्स है प्रोसेसेस है करते हो डीएनएस
एन्यूमरेशन कर दिया फिंगर प्रिंटिंग कर
दिया कंटेंट डिस्कवरी कर दिया
जावास्क्रिप्ट रिकॉन कर दिया एंड सीआईडीआर
से आप आईपी निकालते हो जो कि हमने निकाला
एंड डीएनएस को भी आप बेसिकली डीएनएस को
डीएनएस ब्रूट फोर्स करते हो आप रिजॉल्व
करते हो उससे भी आप आईपी निकालते हो तो
हमने ने आईपी निकाला और आईपी के ऊपर हम
क्या करते हैं एसएन की डिटेल आईपी से हम
एसएन की डिटेल फाइंड करते हैं
ज्योग्राफिकल आईपी एड्रेसस फाइंड करते हैं
पोर्ट स्कैनिंग करते हैं जिसमें सबसे
इंपॉर्टेंट क्या है आपका पोर्ट
स्कैनिंग सबसे इंपॉर्टेंट क्या है पोट
स्कैनिंग इधर ध्यान दे लो कौन कहां का है
उसमें बताओ ठीक है प्लीज डोंट गो ऑन दैट
यहां
पे यहां पे ध्यान दे लो तो हम यहां पे यह
पूरा मेथड फॉलो करते हैं वी फॉलो ऑल दिस
स्टेप ल दिस स्टेप तो हमने कंपनी का अभी
क्या किया डोमेन फाइंड किया सीआईडीआर
फाइंड कर लिया हम अभी सब डोमेन पे नहीं गए
हैं वर्टिकल वाले पे हमने बस एक
हॉरिजॉन्टल वाला जो है हॉरिजॉन्टल हमारा
रिलेशन उस पे गए हैं और हमारा सीआईडीआर
एंड आईपी ब्लॉक्स पे गए हैं जहां पे हमने
आईपी ब्लॉक्स फाइंड कर ली है ये सारी
चीजें हमने फाइंड की है ठीक है अब यहां पे
कुछ और चीजें हैं जिस कुछ और टूल्स हैं
जिनको आप यूज कर सकते हो ये टूल्स मैंने
आपको सारी बता दी हैं जो यहां पे लिस्टेड
है आपके सीआईडीआर आईपी ब्लॉक्स बीजीपी ए
एसएन हु इज रिवर्स एंड चार्ज जीपीटी
एक्विजिशन लिस्टिंग एंड आप एनएस लुकअप का
यूज़ कर सकते हैं नेम सर्वर्स के लिए अभी
फिलहाल आपको ज्यादा यूज़ नहीं आएगा इसका
हम इसको बाद में देखेंगे फर्द कोई दिक्कत
नहीं है एनए लुकअप बेसिकली एक कमांड होती
है यूटिलिटी जिससे आप अलग-अलग तरह के कुछ
क्वेरीज कर सकते हैं एंड वो फिर आपको
रिटर्न देते हैं पर्टिकुलर नेम सवर के
बारे में जानना हो
mx0 रिकॉर्ड के बारे में जानना हो ये सब
आप जान सकते हैं चलिए अब यहां पे एक और
टूल है बिल्ट विथ एंड वेपराइजर मैं आपको
एक एक्सटेंशन के बारे में मैं बताता हूं
बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट एक्सटेंशन है उसको जरूर
आप यूज कीजिएगा दैट एक्सटेंशन इज लाइजर यह
आपको
जो आपको किसी टेक्नोलॉजी के बारे में
डिटेल देता है बहुत सारी डिटेल आपको
प्रोवाइड कर देता है किसी भी टेक्नोलॉजी
के ऊपर में ठीक है जैसे मैं मान लो कोई भी
एक वेबसाइट विजिट कर रहा हूं मैं अपनी ही
वेबसाइट विजिट कर रहा हूं de.com पे अब
जैसे ही मैंने विजिट किया मुझे इसकी
डिटेल्स अगर ये वेपराइजर में जो भी
डिटेल्स पॉपलेट होगी आपको मिल जाएगी जैसे
कौन सा सीएमएस यूज़ हो रहा है वर्डप्रेस
यूज़ हो रहा है 6.4.2 वर्जन आ रही है ठीक
है वर्जन हाइड नहीं किया है इस वजह से
यहां पे ये दिख रहा है उसके बाद कौन सी
मार्केटिंग ऑटोमेशन के लिए टूल यूज हो रही
है फिर उसके बाद एनालिटिक के लिए क्या
यूज़ हो रहा है ब्लॉग के लिए कौन सा यूज़
हो रहा है जावास्क्रिप्ट लाइब्रेरीज
कौन-कौन से हैं पेस बिल्डर कोई है तो क्या
है जावास्क्रिप्ट फ्रेमवर्क्स कौन से यूज़
हो रहे हैं कोई वीडियो प्लेयर है तो क्या
है फॉन्ट स्क्रिप्ट्स क्या यूज हो रहे हैं
यूआई के फ्रेमवर्क्स क्या यूज हो रहे हैं
मिसलेनियस में क्या-क्या है वर्डप्रेस थीम
कौन सा है और अ अलग-अलग प्लगिंस कौन-कौन
से हैं होस्टिंग कौन सी है यह सब कुछ
जितनी डिटेल्स चाहे यह आपको मिल रहे हैं
तो यह काफी एक अच्छा एक एक्सटेंशन है आप
इसको जरूर रखिएगा दूसरा एक वेबसाइट है
builtwith.com
वेरी वेरी वेरी इंटरेस्टिंग वेबसाइट लेट्स
ओपन builtwith.com यह भी एक टेक्नोलॉजी
प्रोफाइलर वेबसाइट है बट बहुत शानदार
वेबसाइट है यह फ्री में पांच या 10 10
क्वेरीज देता है शायद बाकी आपको परचेस
करना पड़ेगा अब आपको किसी वेबसाइट के बारे
में डिटेल में जानकारी चाहिए ना भैया तो
यहां से आपको मिलेगी बहुत डिटेल में
मिलेगी जैसे मान लो मैं facebook.com
हमारी इस पे चलते हैं तो facebook.com इस
पे चलते हैं हम इसको लुक अप करते हैं अब
यह facebook.com को लुक अप करेगा एंड आपको
कंप्लीट रिलेशनशिप
facebooksignup.in करने के लिए दैट टूल इज
नोन एज ए मैस चलिए काली में रूट काली में
हम बूट करते
हैं बूटिंग इनटू द
काली हेयर इट इज इंसाइड द काली काली के
अंदर हम आते हैं टर्मिनल को ओपन कर लेते
हैं एंड यहां थोड़ा सा मैं फंट इंक्रीज कर
लेता हूं देर इज अ टूल नेम एमस अब य एमस
टूल कैसा टूल है मैं आपको बता देता हूं
आपके यहां चलते हैं एंड यहां पर एस को ओपन
कर लेते हैं लेट्स अपन एस
एमस गिट हब येय एंटर करते हैं एस यहां पे
आ जाएगा आपका टूल य यहां पे यहां पे आपको
दिख जाएगा ओस एमएस प्रोजेक्ट ये ओस
प्रोजेक्ट के अंदर जा चुका है पहले यह
स्टैंड अलोन टूल था बाद में ओस में
इंटीग्रेट किया गया इसको ओस एमएस
प्रोजेक्ट परफॉर्म्स नेटवर्क मैपिंग ऑफ
अटैक सरफेस एंड एक्सटर्नल एसेट डिस्कवरी
यूजिंग ओपन सोर्स इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग
ओसेंट का यूज करता है एंड एक्टिव रिकॉन
सेंस टेक्निक ये बहुत शानदार टूल है
एक्टिव रिकॉन सेस टेक्निक का यूज करके एंड
मतलब बहुत सारी चीजें आपको फाइंड करके
देता है कौन-कौन से टेक्निक्स का यूज किया
गया इसके अंदर में एपीआई का एपीआई में
कहां-कहां से एपीआई लिए गए हैं कौन-कौन से
एपीआई टेक्निक का यूज करके कौन-कौन से
एपीआई का यूज किया गया है ये सारे 360d
360 पैसिव डीएनएस एचआरएफ एबस डीएफ बहुत
सारे हैं भाईया वायरस टोटल यूआरएल स्कैन
थ्रेड माइनर थ्रेड बुक नक्स सब डोमेन
सेंटर पेंटेस टूल्स सबसे सर्टिफिकेट्स
कहां-कहां से ग्रैब किए गए हैं देखिए सी
एसए ठीक है सर्च स्पॉटर फ सीटी सब जगह से
डीएनएस के लिए ये किया गया है राउटिंग के
लिए सारे यूज किए गए हैं स्क्रैप यहां से
की गई है वेब आर्काइव का भी यूज किया गया
है ईज का भी यूज किया गया सब चीजें
इंक्लूडेड है इस टूल में भैया सब चीजें
एवरीथिंग इज इड अब इसको यूज कैसे करना है
तो भैया काली को यूज करने का एक फायदा है
काली रिपोजिटरी में ऐसे टूल्स भर भर के
आपको मिल जाएंगे तो काली रिपोजिटरी में
एमएस लिस्ट कीजिए ए मैस कीजिए आपको
रिपोजिटरी में ये टूल मिल जाएगा एंड ये
टूल ऑटोमेटिक इंस्टॉल आती है अब आपके काली
के साथ तो आपको कहीं से कुछ इंस्टॉल नहीं
करना है खाली इंस्टॉल कीजिए टूल ऑटोमेटिक
इंस्टॉल्ड मिलेगी बट स्टिल आपको इंस्टॉल
करना हो तो चलिए ऐड आई है तो इसको मैं
थोड़ा वेट कर लेता हूं चलिए एप्ट इंस्टॉल
एस ये करना है एंटर करना है और आपका
इंस्टॉल हो जाएगा ऑलरेडी इंस्टॉल आपका
दिखा रहा है चलिए यूज करना है एस हान h
हेल्प फाइल के लिए ये कर दीजिएगा इसकी
हेल्प फाइल ओपन होके आ जाएगी यहां पे
मैनुअल एंट्री है क्या कोई एएस की देख
लेते हैं मैनुअल एंट्री नहीं है तो हमें
हेल्प फाइल से ही काम चलाना पड़ेगा हाइन
कीजिएगा अब यहां पे जब आप हाफ करेंगे तो
यहां पे फिलहाल ये दो सब कमांड शो कर रहा
है एए
यहां पे और इसके सब कमांड्स आपको मिल
जाएंगे कि
होगा सामने लाइट्स जल रही होती है रिंग
लाइट्स होती है वो वो बहुत ज्यादा फोकस
मारती है आंखों प ट्स वाई थोड़ा सा वो
होता है आंखों में बट ठीक है
चलो अब यहां पर आ चुके हैं चलिए अब यहां
पर आपको एमस इंटेल को कैसे यूज करना है
एमस लिखना है कमांड इंटेल देना है देन देन
आपको ऑप्श देने
हैं ऑप्शंस कौन से ऑप्शंस ये सारे ऑप्शंस
यहां पर हैं एंड उसके बाद आपको जो भी
चीजें देनी है यहां पर दे रखा है जैसे अगर
आपको हु इज रिकॉर्ड चाहिए किसी भी कंपनी
का किसी डोमेन का तो न हु इज लगाया नडी
दिया डोमेन नेम दे दिया कैसे करना है एए
intel.com चाहिए एंटर कर दिया अब ये
facebook.com का जो भी हु इज इंफॉर्मेशन
है ट्राई करेगा आपको फिच करके प्रोवाइड
करने का तो आपको वेट करना है इसके
रिजल्ट्स का एंड इट विल गिव यू द हु इज
इंफॉर्मेशन इसके अलावा ये तो टूल है हु इज
इंफॉर्मेशन के लिए आप जनरली डायरेक्टली हु
इज कमांड भी यूज कर सकते हैं काली में हु
इज facebook.com
तो ये आपको जो है हु इज जो एंट्री है वो
आपको प्रोवाइड कर देगा facebook.com की
ठीक है वैसे भी कर सकते हैं आप इसका भी
यूज़ कर सकते हैं एस टूल का यूज कर सकते
हैं अब ये टूल क्या है ये टूल थोड़ा आपके
लिए स्लो काम कर सकता है थोड़ा सा टाइम ले
सकता है बट वर्थ टाइम होगा जो यह टाइम
लेगा वर्थ होगा आपको बहुत ब सारी
इंफॉर्मेशन आपको प्रोवाइड करेगा आपको
रिजल्ट्स प्रोवाइड करेगा ठीक है तो इस
तरीके से आप अलग-अलग ऑप्शंस का यूज इसमें
कर सकते हैं अब जैसे मुझे क्या चाहिए मुझे
चाहिए मान लो आईपी एड्रेस का कोई या एसएन
नंबर से डिटेल्स चाहिए एसएन नंबर की चाहिए
पूरी लिस्ट तो मुझे हान एए लगाना है एंड
एए नंबर डाल देना है तो
facebooksignup.in ठीक है हमने एंटर कर
दिया अब ये स्टार्ट करेगा एएन से जो भी
इसके डोमेंस हैं जो भी इसके वो सारे
प्रोवाइड करना आपको शुरू कर देगा तो आपको
थोड़ा वेट करना पड़ेगा इसके रिजल्ट्स के
लिए एंड देन इट विल स्टार्ट शोइंग द
रिजल्ट्स ग्रैजुअली तो थोड़ा वेट कीजिए
ऑटोमेटिक आपको रिजल्ट्स दिखने शुरू हो
जाएंगे इसके जस्ट वेट एंड
वच सर ब्लू ब्लॉक वाला चश्मा ले लो अ
चश्मा ब्लू ब्लॉक वाला हां यार वही करना
पड़ेगा फिलहाल मेरे पास गॉगल्स टाइप है एक
वो लगा लू शायद पता नहीं अंधेरा हो जाएगा
शायद हां ये सही है यार ये भी सही लग रहा
है मतलब आंखों को रिलैक्स तो दे रहा है ये
तो इसको यूज किया जा सकता है टेंपररी
बेसिस पे ये देखिए एस ए वाला जो चीज है वो
काम कर रहा है आपके सामने सामने आपके जो
डोमस है वो निकल के आ रहे हैं इस एन
से बहुत सारे डोमेंस आपको फाइंड करके देगा
हम नाइस कैसा लग रहा है मैंने लगा लिया
थोड़ा इजी तो पड़ रहा है यार थोड़ा इजी
दिखने में लग रहा है अब
तो इजी लग रहा है बहुत आंखों पे यह लगा
लेने से
बढ़िया हालांकि ये सन ग्लासेस है बट स्टिल
अब ये आपको रिजल्ट्स दे रहा है ऐसे आपको
बहुत सारी लिस्ट पूरी दे देगा थोड़ी वही
है ना आप जब ये मैं तभी बोलता हूं जब
आप वीपीएस वगैरह का यूज करोगे क्लाउड में
मशीन यूज करोगे बहुत फास्ट ये काम करेंगी
आपके लोकल मशीन पर थोड़ा स्लो काम करता है
तो थोड़ा आपको बेयर अप करना ही पड़ेगा
सही लग रहा है क्या स्पेक्स लगा के बढ़िया
ना मस् ना
चलिए
ओके यह बढ़िया था गु
बढ़िया रिंग लाइट भी दिख रहा अब तो वाह
क्या बात है रिंग लाइट भी दिख रहा
है रप चिक दिख रहा है अरे भाई ऐसे मत बोला
करो यार चलो तो ये डोमस की लिस्ट आपको
देगा थोड़ा इसमें टाइम आपको लगेगा आप इसके
साथ और भी चीजें कर सकते हैं यू कैन गेट अ
गेट टू सी अ लॉट ऑफ ऑप्शंस हियर जो आपको
यहां पे प्रोवाइड की जाती है यहां पे जैसे
आप एक् अटेंप्ट सर्टिफिकेट नेम ग्रैप्स भी
आप कर सकते हैं जो सर्टिफिकेट नेम ग्रैप्स
आपके लिए आपको करके देगा ठीक है आईपी
एड्रेस या उसकी रेंज डाल के भी आप इसमें अ
उसकी डिटेल्स जो है वो फाइंड कर सकते हैं
सीआईडीआर वैल्यू आप दे सकते हैं सीआईडीआर
वैल्यू डालिए एंड आपको ये क्या दे देगा
आईपी की रेंजेस आईपी एड्रेसस जो है वो
आपको प्रोवाइड कर देगा जैसे मेरे पास एक
सी आईडिया रेंज है
होंगे इसलिए वीपीएस या क्लाउड को यूज़
करना अ सही रहता है जब आप एक इंटरमीडिएट
लेवल पे आ जाते हैं स्टार्टिंग के लिए
बिगनर के लिए यू कैन गो विद द लोकल मशीन
यू कैन हंट ऑन लोकल मशीन स्टिल आपके यह एस
काफी काम आएगा एस को हम यूज़ बहुत ज्यादा
करने वाले हैं आने वाले टाइम में आने वाले
हमारे क्लासेस में जब हम सब डोमेन नरेशन
करेंगे बहुत ज्यादा यूज़फुल होगा अब देखिए
आईपी ड्रेसेस की जो पूरी लिस्ट आपको दे
रहा है आपके उसके होस्ट नेम्स आपको
प्रोवाइड कर रहा है जो भी सीआईडी रेंज के
अंदर में जो आईपी ड्रेसेस हैं यहां पे
आपको प्रोवाइड कर रहा है ठीक
है चलिए धन्यवाद भाई
धन्यवाद देखिए इसने निकालना शुरू कर दिया
एपीआई की कैसे निकालते हैं बहुत इजी है
एपीआई की निकालना है उसके पर्टिकुलर जैसे
वायरस टोटल है उसका आपको एपीआई की निकालना
है तो भैया उस परे लॉग इन करो और सेटिंग्स
में जाओ वायरस
टोटल मान लो एपीआई की वायरस टोटल का
निकालना है मुझे इसका एपीआई की निकालना है
मैं इसके सिंपली इसके अपने अकाउंट में
लॉगइन कर लूंगा साइन इन करूंगा यहां पे
मैं किसी भी
कोई भी कर लो यार ग से साइन इन कर लो कुछ
भी कर लो यहां से ग कंटिन्यू विद ग कर
लेते हैं ठीक है तो यहां पर हमने ग से
साइन इन कर लिया मान लो मैं किसी से भी एक
मान लो इससे मैं ग से साइन इन कर लेता हूं
ठीक है तो मैंने यहां पर ग से साइन इन कर
लिया होप फुली साइन इन हो जाना
चाहिए कुछ गड़बड़ हो रही है यार पता नहीं
साइन इन करोगे अकाउंट में जाओगे सेटिंग्स
में जाओगे वहां प आपको एपीआई कीज मिल
जाएंगी ठीक है उतना ज्यादा टेंशन नहीं
लेना अपने को ठीक है चलिए तो ये आपको एमस
का आप यूज कर सकते हो एमस का इंस्टॉलेशन
आप इंस्टॉल करके प इंस्टॉल करके एस का यूज
कर लीजिएगा ट्स इट बस बस ठीक
है मैट दिखाओ मैट कौन सा होता है भैया मैट
कौन सी होती है तो बताओ कौन सी मैट होती
है
यार हां पल्लव टेलीग्राम पर कांटेक्ट करो
पल्लव मैं बता दूंगा मैं बता
दूंगा जो भी लोग ट्राई हैक म का पेड
प्रीमियम सब्सक्रिप्शन महंगा वाला नहीं
अफोर्ड कर पाते हैं ट्राई हैक मी प
कांटेक्ट कीजिए सॉरी ग्रा प कांटेक्ट
कीजिए मैं आपको एक तरीका बताऊंगा आपको
आपको बहुत ज्यादा बेनिफिट होगा उससे ठीक
है तरीका बता दूंगा आपको ठीक है टे ग्रा प
कांटेक्ट कर सकते हैं एंड दिस इज @
ऑफिशल अटी ए यह वाला टेलीग्राम हैंडल है
आप इस पर कर सकते हैं
टेलीग्राम ठीक है डाल दिया
है अबे अरे अरे अरे किसको कर
दिया चलिए
अंडो ठीक है जिनको ट्रामी का मतलब व वाउचर
चाहि जैसे मतलब पेड महंगा लगता है टे ग्रा
पर कांटेक्ट मैं आपको तरीका बता दूंगा
कैसे लाइक यू कैन गेट
चीपर
ओके चलो
बढ़िया चश्मा वाई क्योंकि बहुत ज्यादा जोर
पड़ रहा था आंखों पे
यार चलिए ठीक है
ओके तो यह हमने देखा यहां पे गैदरिंग इंटल
गैदरिंग हमने देखी हमने अलग-अलग तरीके
अलग-अलग तरीके देखे हमने अलग-अलग स्टेप्स
देखे यहां पे एंड हमने देखा यहां पे कि हम
कैसे क्याक निकाल रहे हैं आईपी ब्लॉक्स
फाइंड कर सकते हैं उसमें आईपी रेंजेस
फाइंड कर सकते हैं हॉरिजॉन्टल डोमेंस कैसे
हम फाइंड करना है हमें एक पूरी एक्विजिशंस
कैसे फाइंड करनी है उसके डोमस को कैसे
फाइंड करना है रिलेटेड सब डोमेंस को कैसे
निकालना है ये सारी चीजें देखी
हमने बिल्ट विथ अब यहां पे आ चुके हैं ये
लोड हो चुका है देखिए बिल्ट विथ वाला अब
ये देखो टैग हिस्ट्री एंड रिलेशनशिप
तुम्हें अब दिख रहा होगा ना यहां पे ये ऐड
वाली आईडी से तुम्हें रिलेशनशिप बता रहे
हैं ये आईपी एड्रेस की हिस्ट्री एंड
रिलेशनशिप बता रहे है ये बहुत बड़ी चीज है
आपको अभी समझ नहीं आ रहा है बट जैसे आप
किसी एक रिलेशनशिप पे क्लिक कीजिए जैसे इस
वाले पे मैंने क्लिक किया अब वेट कीजिए अब
जैसे ही मैंने क्लिक किया यहां पे आपको ये
लिस्ट ऑफ डोमेंस आपको प्रोवाइड कर देता है
ये देखो ये कुछ डोमेंस आपको प्रोवाइड कर
देता है लास्ट डिटेक्टेड कब हुई थी ये
प्रोवाइड कर देता है जैसे मे careers.com
ये एक डोमेन नेम अब यहां जो डोमेन मिली अब
इस पे हम फर्द आप टेस्ट करना शुरू करेंगे
इसके सब डोमस फाइंड करेंगे एंड इसकी चीजों
पे हम काम करना शुरू कर देंगे समझ में आ
गया तो ये आपको लिस्ट प्रोवाइड कर देता है
ये बहुत इसलिए बहुत ज्यादा इंटरेस्टिंग
चीज है ये चलो बैक हो जाते हैं अब मान लो
मैंने इस पे किया इस पे क्लिक किया मैं
लेट्स क्लिक ऑन दिस एंड वेट फॉर द रिजल्ट
अब यहां पे कुछ और यहां पे यूआरएल आ गए
आपकी डोमेंस आ गई अब इन डोमेंस पे भी हम
चेक आउट कर सकते हैं इन डोमेंस को हम
लिस्ट में डाल सकते हैं अपने टारगेट में
स्कोप में डाल सकते हैं इस पे भी हम फरदर
सब डोमस फाइंड करने की कोशिश कर सकते हैं
ये समझ में आ गया आपको अच्छा आप सब लोग
मुझे ईमानदारी ऑनेस्टली एंड बहुत ही
ऑनेस्टली बताओ आपको प्रोसेस समझ में आ रहा
है ना मैं ये सारे प्रोसेस बता रहा हूं
गाइस ये अभी मैंने अब तक सब डोमेन
न्यूमरेशन नहीं करा है यह तो उसके पहले के
जितने डोमस है उनको कलेक्ट करने का पूरा
प्रोसेस था आज की क्लास में जितने डोमस थे
और जितने आईपी एड्रेसस थे ठीक है तो आपको
सिंपल एसएन
नंबर
मतलब अरीन हुज अरीन हुज यहां से आपको
बताया था अरीन
हुज ठीक है अरीन हुई से आपने एसएन नंबर
निकाल लिया एसएन नंबर से आपने यहां से से
आईपी ब्लॉक्स निकाल ली सीआईडी रेंज
ब्लॉक्स निकाल ली सीआई रें से आईपी एड्रेस
निकाल दिया और सारे सब डोमेंस निकाल लिए
गॉट इट सभी को समझ में आ गया
इतना एवरीवन गॉट राइट चलिए अब हम नेक्स्ट
सेशन से लाइव सब डोमेन नमरे करेंगे
कुछ लाइक गिट हब रिकॉन भी करने वाले हैं
बहुत सारी चीजें करने वाले हैं तो नेक्स्ट
सेशन से हम यह काम करेंगे आज के सेशन के
लिए हम बस यहीं पे एंड करते हैं यह हमारे
सोशल मीडिया हैंडल्स हैं आप इन पे आइए एंड
इन से हम कनेक्ट हो सकते हैं हमारे
देता हूं सभी को दे देता हूं ताकि जो भी
यहां जॉइड है उनको यह चीज का लुफ मिल जाए
इस पर कूपन कोड अप्लाई कर लीजिएगा
डिक्स 500 डि फ्रक्स 500 कूपन कोड एंड इस
पर आपको एक्स्ट्रा 500 का डिस्काउंट मिल
जाएगा बस आज रात तक वैलिड होगा आप इसको
ट्राई आप इसको कर लीजिएगा एंड यू विल गेट
द डिस्काउंट
ओके बस यह वाला यूज कर लीजिएगा इस वाले
लिंक प अगर आप हमारे एथिकल हैकिंग कोर्स
में इनरोल करना चाहते हैं कंप्लीट कोर्स
में यू कैन कम एंड जॉइन विद दिस अ कूपन
कोड ठीक
है चलिए मैंने इसको पिन भी कर दिया
है आज रात तक का ही है यह जो भी है ठीक है
तो आज के सेशन के लिए बस इतना ही करते हैं
एंड मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट सेशन में कल आपकी
पूरी हॉलीडे होगी कल आपका कोई भी सेशन
नहीं होगा न्यू ईयर सेलिब्रेट कीजिए एंड
सभी को विश यू ऑल अ वेरी वेरी हैप्पी न्यू
ईयर इन एडवांस एंड मे दिस न्यू ईयर
ब्रिंग्स अ लॉट ऑफ जॉय एंड मे ऑल योर
डिजर्स अ कम ट्रू व्हिच आर गुड जो आपके
गुड डिजायर्स है वो ट्रू हो जाए गुड आपके
ड्रीम्स जो है व स वो जो है आपके सच हो
जाए एंड आपको सारी प्रोस्पेरिटी जो है सब
कुछ मिले इस न्यू ईयर पे ठीक है तो बस
गाइस आज के सेशन के लिए इतना ही अब इस
वीडियो को अपने दोस्तों के भी शेयर कर दो
पूरा फैला दो चारों तरफ बस इतना ही मांगा
है आपसे और कुछ मांगा भी नहीं है बस इतना
ही मांगा है कि वीडियो को शेयर करो अपने
दोस्तों के बीच शेयर कर दो इतना ही सपोर्ट
और प्यार दिखाओ हमारे लिए बहुत है इतना
बहुत ज्यादा आप अभी तक सपोर्ट दिखा रहे हो
कंटिन्यू रखो हम आपको क्वालिटी कंटेंट
देते रहेंगे पूरी बग बाउंट की जर्नी आपको
वोह प्रो लेवल प लेकर जाएंगे जो मैंने
आपको वादा किया है उस परे लेकर जाऊंगा ही
जाऊंगा लिख के रखो इस बात को ठीक है
ओके ठीक है चलिए थैंक यू सो मच गाइस थैंक
यू सो सो मच थैंक यू सो मच थैंक यू
गाइस थैंक यू वेरी मच जवाइन करने के लिए
मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट लाइव सेशन में एंड अभी
के लिए टाटा बाय बाय सबको एक बार सभी लोग
बाय बाय कर दो गुड नाइट हैप्पी न्यू
ईयर सभी लोग बाय कर दो जल्दी से मैं भी कर
देता हूं गुड नाइट सबको टाटा बाय
बाय
ओके
चलो
चलिए दबा के शेयर
कीजिए एंड सबको
टाटा थैंक
यू हैप्पी न्यू ईयर गुड
नाइट एंड एंजॉय द न्यू ईयर